foreign
[Music]
this weekend I watched one of the
biggest hits on Netflix right now which
is a documentary series from a
journalist named Graham Hancock the show
is called ancient apocalypse and in the
series just as he has throughout his
career Hancock argues that there was a
lost Global civilization that existed on
Earth some 12 000 years ago but it was
wiped out in a cataclysm
that erased most traces of this
civilization he claims that our
ancestors had a memory of this cataclysm
the the ancient Apocalypse in the title
which they recounted in the biblical
story of the flood and in other ancient
texts around the world
the way he puts it you know he says that
we are a a species with amnesia we don't
know the story of our own past and we
accept what we've been told by
mainstream science and Academia which
insists that there were was no you know
there were no civilizations at all in
fact certainly not Advanced ones prior
to about 4000 BC that's the mainstream
accepted version of events
um Hancock says that they're ignoring or
even potentially covering up evidence to
the contract
and what is the evidence well
much of it centers around various
ancient structures around the world that
have turned out to be much older than
they originally thought to be Hancock
points to for example
um one thousand-year-old pyramids that
as it turns out were built over top even
older pyramids which were built over
older ones like the kind of Russian
nesting doll sort of situation the
evidence indicates that that our
ancestors were in fact building bigger
and more complicated things earlier than
previously assumed
and so Hancock is is pointing to some of
this also there's the similarity between
these ancient structures like the
Egyptians weren't the only ones who
built pyramids obviously ancient people
all over the world made their own
versions of pyramids and they were
usually built to correspond with
astronomical phenomena
why did all these societies separated by
oceans and millennia
decide to build these structures and how
did they build them
that's an interesting question and one
that has never been sufficiently
answered Graham Hancock's answer is that
the survivors of a lost Ice Age
civilization went around the world
passing down the knowledge of how to
build these pyramids along with teaching
Agriculture and architecture and art Etc
um
and that's how they figured out how to
do it now why did these survivors do
this and how did they survive the
apocalypse that wiped out their
civilization and where were they
stationed for the centuries that would
have taken them to go around the whole
world teaching these techniques to
thousands of different societies and how
were they able to communicate with all
these people speaking different
languages and why isn't there any actual
material evidence of this Advanced
civilization that supposedly existed 12
000 years ago
Hancock says that it was wiped out in a
cataclysm but he also says that there
were enough survivors to support this
Global campaign to civilize the entire
world which means that there were a lot
of survivors
uh why didn't they leave behind any
direct evidence of their existence
these questions and many more are not
answered by Graham Hancock
which is why
I don't personally buy much of what he's
selling I am not persuaded
and yet
I very much enjoyed the series just as
I've enjoyed listening to him explain
his ideas during his several appearances
on Joe Rogan's podcast I've read one of
his books I found it interesting
um I think his theory is
are quite interesting and entertaining
and also outlandish and probably dead
wrong
despite what you've been told it is
possible to have this opinion about
someone or something it is possible to
believe that someone is wrong
and yet still find them fascinating
it is possible to disagree with
someone's ideas
and yet still believe that the ideas are
worth listening to
say whatever else you want about Graham
Hancock he is to use the cliche in
outside the box thinker and I can
personally always appreciate those types
of people we need more of those people
in the world not fewer they make life
more interesting they make conversations
more interesting
and they get people talking about
subjects that they would otherwise
ignore I mean a show about ancient
archeology is now the biggest hit on
Netflix
which I think as someone who enjoys
history that's that's worth celebrating
in its own right even if you reject his
hypothesis completely
this is not a difficult needle to thread
okay it's not hard to say
I disagree with your ideas
but I'm glad you've shared them
at least it shouldn't be hard
yet it's somehow beyond the capacity of
the mainstream media which has one word
for ideas that fall outside of the
mainstream well they have a few words
but one of the most uh the most common
words is it's the word is not
interesting but rather dangerous
and it's dangerous if it falls outside
of the mainstream hence many headlines
published over the past few days like
this one from the guardian says ancient
apocalypse is the most dangerous Show on
Netflix
and then the subheader of that article
says this
a show with a truly Preposterous theory
is one of the streaming Giants biggest
hits and it seems to exist solely for
conspiracy theorists why has this been
allowed
wait why has it been allowed
who is supposed to disallow it
well the writer never explains that he
also never really explains what exactly
makes a Preposterous quote-unquote
theory about ancient prehistory
dangerous
what is the danger precisely
so a bunch of people come to believe
that an advanced civilization existed
during the last ice age and and then
what what catastrophe is supposed to
follow from that
other articles have taken it a step
further claiming that the show is not
only dangerous but racist as well a
headline from a different publication
declares that there is a whole bunch of
quote white supremacist nonsense behind
Netflix's ancient apocalypse
yet Hancock never says anything about
race in the show or in his books as far
as I know
even if you think that his Lost
Civilization theory is the dumbest thing
you've ever heard in your life what in
the world makes it racist
well that's never explained either but
it doesn't have to be we already know
that this is the media's version of
Tourette's they just reflexively blurred
out the word racist when faced with
anything they don't like everything they
personally disapprove of is racist and
dangerous
as for the latter charge the best
attempt at an explanation comes from the
guardian article I mentioned which
arrives at this conclusion at the end it
says that's the danger of a show like
this it Whispers to the conspiracy
theorist in all of us and Hancock is
such a compelling host that he's bound
to create a few more in his wake
believing that Ultra intelligent
creatures help to build the pyramids is
one thing but where does it end
believing that election fraud is real
believing 9 11 was an inside job worse
if you were feeling particularly
mean-spirited you could suggest that
Netflix knows this and has gone out of
its way to court the conspiracy
theorists
ah so there it is if you question the
narrative from mainstream archaeologists
the fear is that it might send you
tumbling down a rabbit hole where you
begin to think critically and
skeptically about a whole host of other
topics as well
like election integrity
this is indeed a dangerous possibility
dangerous anyway to the people in charge
of formulating and disseminating the
official narrative
I mean this is really the sin that
Graham Graham Hancock has committed he's
pointing out holes in the official story
he's encouraging skepticism
now the theories that he formulates may
have many holes of their own I think
they do but that's not the issue as far
as the narrative Gatekeepers are
concerned
I mean they don't care if something is
wrong they themselves are wrong all the
time wrongness is not a problem for them
the problem is when people notice how
little they The Gatekeepers actually
know
how how fragile and tentative their own
theories are
how unearned and unjustified is their
confidence
that's what makes a documentary series
about ancient archeology dangerous
is that it might make you a little
skeptical of The Gatekeepers
which I guess is dangerous yeah but it's
the right kind of dangerous
and that is why it's not Graham Hancock
who's canceled today but The Gatekeepers
trying to shame and silence him they are
all canceled that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]